It couldn't really end like this, could it?
Not after what I'd just been through.
We're gonna get through this, right?
We're gonna be together forever, right?
I'm starting to think otherwise.
Maybe Justin Bieber was right.
Maybe there was no Juliet for this Romeo.
No Meg Ryan for this Tom Hanks.
Maybe there was no such thing as love.
And just as I was about to resign myself to a life of cat ownership, I saw her.
The girl of my dreams.
I had to think fast.
A train leaves the station travelling at 27 miles per hour.
The next station is 14 city blocks away.
If a man leaves that same station on foot but takes one massive shortcut,...
...will he spend the rest of his life alone?
I was incredibly out of shape.
But every fiber of my being told me I couldn't let this one go.
I had to keep pushing.
I was going to make it!
I wasn't going to make it.
What was this?
Wait a minute!
Bieber!
And just like that, she was gone.
The next station wasn't for miles.
I had nothing left but a flat tire and a broken heart.
It couldn't really end like this, could it?
Not after what I'd just been through.
We're gonna get through this, right?
We're gonna be together forever, right?
I'm starting to think otherwise.
Maybe Justin Bieber was right.
Maybe there was no Juliet for this Romeo.
No, no Courtney Love for this Kurt Cobain.
Maybe there was no such thing as love.
And just as I was about to renew my World of Warcraft membership, I saw her.
The girl of my dreams.